so what i want to do is if we know what
x and y are for example if i gave you a
complex number like 3 plus 4i
i'd like to know how do we work out what
the theta
and vr that distance i want to know how
to find those out
okay so here's the way we're going to do
it let's try and get a connection
between
our xy and our our theta in order to do
that we need to put a little more
construction onto our diagram right
let's start with this this distance here
this distance here is interesting to me
because it helps me form
some geometric figures that were useful
for me to get the connection between x y
and r theta that distance that i've just
drawn in green
how far up is it you actually know based
on the information we've provided
it's why isn't it because that's how
high up you are so i'm going to label
that guy
as y switching over to another color if
i go down to say
here this
part on the bottom which as you can see
the reason why i've chosen is because it
forms
not just any shape but a right angle
triangle in the same way what is that
length over there
it's x it's a horizontal length right
now because i have
x y r and theta i have all of them
existing
in this same right angle triangle this
is all i need
to get the connection let's have a think
about
r first this is easy right if i want to
know
r what is the piece of knowledge that
connects r
x and y it's pythagoras's theorem right
so i can say uh squared equals
x squared plus y squared these are my
two shorter
sides and because i you know we've
leaned on some knowledge to say that
i want to give us our reasons so this is
from pythagoras
theorem oopsy daisy
now i don't just want r squared i want r
so i'm going to
take the square roots of both sides
thankfully for us
i can disregard one of my two solutions
that i get out of that why can i
disregard one of the solutions
i i don't need to worry about a negative
because
it's uh oh no interesting this is in the
first quadrant that is where i've drawn
it
but because i said an arbitrary complex
number i mean i could have just as
easily put z over here or here or here
so it's less to do with which quadrant
it is what's what's the other piece of
information that helps me get rid of
one of the solutions
yeah very good so because r is a
magnitude is what we would call it right
it's a magnitude i can't have something
negative for it so and i'm going to
state that in a second
so therefore i can just say r is the
positive square root
of x squared plus y squared and we
should say
r is greater than zero
its length never take shortcuts on your
reasoning okay great so i have ah this
is really good
and i can do a similar kind of thought
process to think about
theta right now looking at this look
carefully right
x and y are the things we know um they
are therefore
like the the kind of knowns like three
plus four i for example like once three
one's four
so i know it is very tempting if you
have a look at theta
and you know x and y it's super tempting
to use a particular trigonometric ratio
to get directly to theta which is the
first ratio that
jumps to mind hopefully your mind went
to tan first right because look
if um if theta is the angle i'm
interested in then y
is opposite and x is adjacent so
opposite on adjacent is
tan now it is true and we should jot it
down it is true
that tan theta equals
opposite on adjacent y on x
in this case however and i'm just going
to um i'm going to put a pause on this
and ask us to come back to this later
and for those of you who've
um i think about this i want you to ask
this question
i'm going to encourage you not to say on
the next line
was there for theta equals what would
you do to both sides of this
if you just want theta you would say tan
inverse right
i'm going to encourage you i'm
deliberately not going to write theta
equals
tan inverse y on x i'd love you all to
have a think about
why it seems like i'm avoiding this very
obvious way of getting
the answer i'm going to go away that
looks like it's going to be longer but
i'm going to try and argue later on
is superior instead of saying just say
tan theta right
what i want to say is if i think about
the other ratios like say for example
sine theta
what do you get out of sine theta in
this right angle triangle
y on r which means i can say
y equals r sine
theta do you agree with that that's okay
i should put that in the appropriate
color sorry i think that was green
so you should jot that down because
that's really important and conversely
i can say i've got tan i've got sine the
last one of course is cos
so cos theta in this right angle
triangle is
it's x over r adjacent non-hypotenuse so
therefore i can say
x equals r cos
theta okay now
why is this a better way to go about it
well this argument's going to take a
little way to
unpack but what i really like about this
is it tells me what x and
y are in terms of r and theta so
therefore
see how i've written here that z equals
x plus i y
i can completely replace this in terms
of r's and thetas do you see that
these two equations here allow me to do
that i can say instead of writing
z equals x plus iy i can write
r cos theta plus i y
except i know what i y is as well it's
going to be i
times r sine theta that's what i get
from
this equation in here does that make
sense just a teeny bit more tiny
tidying up i can clearly factorize and
take out a factor of
r and so that leaves me with this guy
r times cos theta plus i
sine theta and we made the heading polar
form
this this equation i've just written
down here this is what we mean by the
polar form of a complex number it's the
same one we started with it's the same
x plus iy but it's no longer just in
terms of
move this way and this way or or that
way and that or whichever way right
it's about an angle of rotation and then
go along
that angle of rotation a particular
distance in this case r
right so we need to add some language to
describe
what is going on so underneath where
you've written the polar form of a
complex number
we can state that r is this distance
from the origin we give it a fancy name
we call it
the modulus of z the modulus
and we have some notation to indicate
the modulus of z
um some old notation actually some
familiar notation you may be like what
is that doing here
we denote it like so it's a z
with absolute value signs around it now
i know this might sound
weird right but actually it aligns with
what we already knew about the absolute
value right
if we said you don't have to write this
down but if we said the absolute value
of something like say
5 we know that's just 5. we just take
the positive value right
conversely if i said the absolute value
of negative five you would repeat to me
five and maybe you're just thinking i'm
just taking the positive value
but can you see this actually fits this
definition here right five and negative
five
are places on the complex plane where
are they
oopsie does you zoom out my fingers are
like two weird or something like that
five and negative five where are they
maybe five is around
here so therefore the distance of this
point to the origin
its modulus will be five right
where's negative five it's yeah it's on
the
other side of the real axis but again if
negative five were here
then its modulus would be how far it is
from the origin would still be five
so that's why we use this same absolute
value notation
and then when we talk about this angle
when we say it's measured from the
positive real axis
anti-clockwise we call it the argument
we're going to introduce another little
abbreviation here
not very creative this time we just say
arg which is short for argument
so augz means what is the angle you have
to rotate
to be pointing at that complex number
okay
okay take a breath um how are you
feeling so far is your brain
doing all right um do you remember i
said i chose this letter r
randomly does anyone want to suggest why
it might be a good letter to choose
any texas so it has to do with the
radius right when you are looking at
uh these guys here this one here and
this one here i wondered if this rang
any bells for you for maybe like
year 10 trigonometry for an x coordinate
being to do with cos and a y coordinate
to do with
sine uh hopefully this reminded you of
a shape that you're um familiar with
namely oops let's get it there
the unit circle right the unit circle
has coordinates everywhere around it
cos theta sine theta for x and y except
this is not necessarily the unit circle
i've got a circle of any size so that's
why we have that r coefficient
out the front okay